[Musik]
corona nachgehakt was wir bisher wissen
omikron lässt die infektionszahlen in
die höhe schießen während gleichzeitig
die zahl der intensivpatienten und der
toten nicht oder noch nicht steigt die
impfquote in deutschland ist zu niedrig
um diese welle zu brechen heißt das also
dass wir in deutschland eine impfpflicht
brauchen darüber möchte ich heute gerne
diskutieren mit professor julian
nida-rümelin er ist der stellvertretende
vorsitzende des deutschen ethikrats und
er ist professor für philosophie mit dem
interessanten spezialgebiet risiko ethik
herzlich willkommen bei corona nach
gehört ja guten tag was können uns die
philosophie und die risiko ethik helfen
wenn wir zwischen gesundheit und
freiheit abwägen müssen also wie andere
disziplinen der wissenschaft auch kann
sie nicht das abnehmen was in den
parlamenten in der öffentlichkeit
geleistet werden muss nämlich bewerten
und am ende gemeinsam entscheidungen
treffen so oder so sie kann nur beraten
so sehe ich die philosophie generell sie
kann für klarheit in den köpfen
gelegentlich sorgen wenn die konfusionen
groß werden liegt manchmal eine
begriffen die durcheinander geworfen
werden manchmal sieht man nicht dass
kriterien sich widersprechen und sie
kann darauf hinweisen
dass diese praxis oder jene praxis
zusammen nicht beide rational sein
können weil sich die maßstäbe nach denen
diese realisiert werden widersprechen
das sind so aufgaben die ich sehe mein
wissenschaftliches thema ist
rationalität praktische rationalität
praktische vernunft und umgang mit
wahrscheinlichkeit mit risiken gehören
da eben dazu jetzt hat der deutsche
ethikrat mit knapper mehrheit für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht für alle ab 18
notiert sie gehören zur minderheit die
das skeptisch sieht warum na ja also es
war 13 zu 11 wenn sie so wollen
das war aber kein machtkampf jetzt im
deutschen ethikrat weil wir es
eigentlich so gesehen haben dass wir
erstmal orientierung geben wollen also
wenn sie diese stellungnahme oder
empfehlungen ad hoc empfehlungen lesen
nach lesbar auf der homepage dann sehen
sie es geht zunächst einmal um die
kriterien die ihr wichtig sind und nicht
so sehr darum was man daraus für eine
schlussfolgerung zieht ich bin
persönlich der meinung das hat auch
einen politischen aspekt wenn fast die
gesamte politik und fast die gesamte
wissenschaft über monate der
öffentlichkeit gesagt hat im pflicht
kommt auf keinen fall in frage manche
ministerpräsidenten haben hinzugefügt
damals es wird auch kein druck ausgeübt
werden auch ungeimpfte und man dann
jetzt nach zwei jahren sagt man jetzt
sehen was doch anders weil die situation
hat sich verändert das ist so ein
argument was da häufig auftaucht ich
habe mich übrigens immer gewundert warum
das so apodiktisch haben dann muss man
wirklich sehr vorsichtig sein das heißt
man sollte da mit diesem instrument so
behutsam wie möglich umgehen und die
frage ist was ist behutsam und da sage
ich ja da müssen wir erst mal klären was
ist das ziel sie sagten eingangs auf dem
reichen die impfquoten nicht aus um die
welle zu brechen mit verlaub ich halte
diese einschätzung die sehr weit
verbreitet ist wenn man die
statistischen daten anschaut schlicht
für falsch
schlicht für falsch bremen hat bei den
erwachsenen
eine impfquote von
98 prozent
98 prozent und hat die höchste oder
jedenfalls eine der höchsten instanzen
gegenwärtig aber ich verstehe sich
richtig sie sagen mit einer hohen
impfquote kann man die welle gar nicht
verkneifen die welle im sinne von
infektionen kann man nach lage der dinge
nicht brechen es mag sein dass es einen
neuen impfstoff gibt der steril ist
wunderbar aber die impfungen die wir
jetzt haben sind nicht steril das heißt
wir infizieren uns und wir geben die
infektionen weiter wenn auch mit
abgesenkter wahrscheinlichkeit wie stark
diese absenkung ist hängt davon ab wie
lange hängt die liegt die impfung zurück
auch vom alter und so weiter ist das
jetzt ein argument gegen jegliche
impfpflicht oder was wäre ihre
alternative und jetzt muss man einfach
klarheit ich werde immer für klarheit
das ist kein argument gegen impfen und
auch nicht gegen pflichten warum weil
die wahrscheinlichkeit schwer zu
erkranken massiv sinkt massiv sinkt das
heißt die kranken lass diejenigen die
hospitalisiert werden müssen die auf
intensivstationen kommen die wenigen die
dann am ende auch noch sterben das sind
ganz überwiegend ungeübte dh die
ungeimpften und zwar nicht beliebigen
alters sondern die ungeimpften älterer
jahrgänge machen dieses risiko aus das
heißt also auf deutsch noch einmal
übersetzt die infektionswelle brechen
wir nicht durch impfungen auch nicht
durch im schlichten die impfungen
vielleicht noch erweitern das ist de
facto nicht der fall sondern was wir tun
es wir senken die mortalität und
morbidität das heißt die anzahl der
personen die schwerkranken die anzahl
der personen die auf intensivstationen
mussten sind massiv durch impfungen und
jetzt nochmal ein zusatz das gilt aber
nicht nach impfquote über die ganze
bevölkerung schaut mal bitte genau hin
ergibt die informationen auf seiner
eigenen homepage
das bild beschränkt sich fast
ausschließlich auf die über 50-jährigen
das ist der teil der bevölkerung das
heißt ihre alternative zu einer
impfpflicht für alle ab 18 wäre eine
altersspezifische impfpflicht ab 50 oder
ab 60 also das ist die lücke die und
sorgen machen muss wir haben also bei
den über 60 jährigen eine hohe impfquote
wenn man so will ich meines wissens
liegt sie jetzt bei 87 prozent oder
sowas aber da sind immer noch fast 3
millionen menschen in deutschland drei
millionen menschen die zum teil hohe
risiken tragen wenn sie sich infizieren
das muss uns sorgen machen nicht die
30-jährigen nicht die 20 jährigen nicht
wie mein sohn achtjähriger wenn er mich
fragt muss ich angst haben vor krone
sagt nein du nicht du musst keine angst
haben die daten sind völlig eindeutig
und für omicron schon gleich gar nicht
sondern das problem ist die älteren vor
erkrankten und da haben wir in
deutschland eine lücke die ist größer
als in großbritannien größer als in
schweden schweden hat ungefähr dieselbe
impfquote wie wir hat aber sehr viel
mehr ältere geimpft bei den jüngeren
weniger geimpft ich werde macht sich
jetzt gerne mal ein haken klar die
mortalität das risiko zu sterben ist bei
den älteren deutlich höher aber dass er
ihr eigenes risiko also warum brauche
ich kann da eine impfpflicht weiterhin
das ist ein wichtiges argument also die
ministerpräsidentin von dänemark das ist
auch schon wieder lange her hat gesagt
wenn alle über 50 1 impfangebot in
dänemark hatten dann hat jeder der
wirklich gefährdet ist eine möglichkeit
sich zu schützen dann werden wir keine
maßnahmen mehr ergreifen daran hat sie
sich nicht gehalten es kam dann auch ein
bisschen anders was spricht dafür dass
wir obwohl die menschen die möglichkeit
haben sich zu impfen jetzt noch mit
einer impfpflicht kommen wir erlauben
den menschen sich jeden abend zu
betrinken das ist nicht gesund belastet
auch die intensivstationen führt zu
leberzirrhose
und tod wir erlauben dass menschen
dürfen sich in einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft selbst schädigen was ist
das argument dass wir dennoch sagen es
spricht für impfpflicht für die
risikogruppen oder für die besonders
gefährdeten in der gesellschaft das
einzige argument was das rechtfertigt
ist wir sind uns alle oder die meisten
einig wir wollen keine triage
situationen wir wollen keine schweren
überlastungen des gesundheitssystems und
nach lage der dinge einschließlich des
auffälligen schonendes von
intensivbetten im laufe dieser pandemie
dass uns auch noch beschäftigen sollte
in der zukunft
haben wir nun eine knappe situation da
ist noch spielraum aber nicht mehr sehr
viel das heißt wir müssen vermeiden dass
jetzt die intensivstationen überlastet
werden und das ärztliche personal vor
schreckliche entscheidungen traf
entscheidungen sind immer schrecklich
gestellt werden wer muss jetzt
gewissermaßen sterben und wer hat die
höhere überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit und
für wen werden die betten vorgehalten
andere die vielleicht herzinfarkt haben
müssen zurückstehen weil sie eben nicht
rechtzeitig behandelt werden das wollen
wir vermeiden und das können wir am
besten vermeiden indem wir die
hochaltrigen und die vor erkrankten
impfen die anhänger eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für alle ab 18 wenn ein das
wird unter umständen nicht ausreichen
weil daneben die korona pandemie und in
den altersklassen unter 50
unvermindert weiter grassiert und damit
dann wieder die alten an also die
meisten die für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht sagen wir mal so eben ab 18
niemand ist bislang für ab fünf das ging
ja auch ermöglicht ab 5 oder ab 12 da
ist es empfohlen von der stiko bis 12 zu
hinten ist bringt das meistens in
verbindung mit der herdenimmunität wir
können herdenimmunität insbesondere bei
econda sehr viel infektiöser ist nicht
erreichen das ist immer das argument
wenn nicht sehr viel mehr menschen
geimpft sind da ist meine antwort
allerdings gut wie gesagt ich schaue nur
drauf ich bin kein epidemiologe aber ich
kann zahlen lesen kann statistiken lesen
also nachhaltige herdenimmunität das ist
meine prognose wird man weiß nie
varianten können auch auftreten und so
aber weniger infektiöse eigentlich nicht
mehr die werden wir ohnehin nicht
erreichen jedenfalls dann nicht wenn die
impfstoffe nicht steril sind wenn sie
dem hohen prozentsatz immer noch
infektionen zu lassen angesichts der
mobilität der weltbevölkerung wir sind
keine wirkliche herde weil die mobilität
so groß ist die weltbevölkerung als
ganze wird jeden immunität nachhaltig
auf keinen fall erreichen durch
impfungen völlig ausgeschlossen das
heißt ich bin skeptisch ob dieses ziel
überhaupt noch vernünftig ist
bis eine impfpflicht egal welcher art
sie ist greift wird es monate dauern das
heißt für diese welle kommt es viel zu
spät
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
sagt wir brauchen diese impfpflicht für
den herbst und für den winter ist das
logisch so zu argumentieren
also es ist logisch wenn man allerdings
sagt jetzt hilft die impfpflicht ohnehin
nicht mehr
dann verstehe ich nicht warum zum teil
dieselben leute sagen schnell schnell es
muss aber jetzt ganz schnell gehen und
vielleicht noch hinzufügen sonst besteht
die gefahr dass das zerredet wird also
mit verlaub wofür haben parlamente um zu
reden um zu argumentieren wofür ein paar
zeitung also wenn eine so wichtige
entscheidung ein so massiver kurswechsel
und zwar nicht nur in der korona
pandemie sondern über die jahrzehnte wir
sind weggegangen von pflichten die gab's
mal packen pflichten gab es einmal wir
sind eigentlich davon abgegangen
ausnahme masern auch das ist aber
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht und da
war die situation eine völlig andere da
war wirklich die chance der ausrottung
der masern gegeben dass es hier nicht
gegeben wir werden immer wieder in dem
ist wie jetzt fast alle sagen wieder
herausgefordert werden durch bewohner
infektion also diejenigen die sagen das
hilft sowieso erst im nächsten herbst
dürfen auf keinen fall zur gleichen zeit
sagen scholz sorge jetzt dafür dass
dadurch regiert wird und übermorgen
entschieden wird das passt nicht
zusammen
auch geimpfte können ansteckend sein ist
das ein argument gegen jegliche
impfpflicht nein das sehe ich eben nicht
so weil das entscheidende kriterium
darüber man im grunde gründlich beraten
öffentlich oder auch intern was ist das
kriterium nachdem die pandemie maßnahmen
ein ende haben
und das fällt uns jetzt auf die füße
dass wir das nie offen diskutiert haben
und nach lage der dinge werden wir keine
erden immunität jedenfalls nicht
nachhaltig also auf dauer erreichen
sondern ich zitiere nur das was
epidemiologen sagen ich bin kein
epidemiologe das wird endemisch werden
das heißt es wird immer wieder auftreten
aber die belastung werden sinken wenn
das so ist dann müssen wir uns überlegen
ab wann brauchen wir keine weiteren
maßnahmen quarantänemaßnahmen testungen
in den schulen schulschließungen
möglicherweise
lockdown und shutdown maßnahmen wann
hören wir damit endgültig auf
und ich sage das ungern weil die leute
so emotional drauf reagieren aber die
risiko ethik kann da nicht ein standard
hervorzaubern aus der ethik die einzige
möglichkeit ist dass wir schauen auf die
praxis die wir allgemein akzeptieren und
ein vergleichsmaßstab ist zweifellos die
regelmäßig auftretende zum beispiel
saisonale influenza und andere
infektionskrankheiten
die risiken durch kurven 19 schwer zu
erkranken oder zu sterben sind ohne
maßnahmen ohne impfung um ein vielfaches
höher alles andere ist quatsch um ein
vielfaches höher jedenfalls bei unserer
demographie
vielleicht in manchen afrikanischen
ländern anders mit junger bevölkerung
mit unserer demokratie um ein vielfaches
höher 6 x 8 x 10 x gut da gehen die
meinungen etwas auseinander aber wenn
wir geimpft sind
new york times hat gestern einen artikel
dazu beschrieben was auch das bestätigt
wenn wir geimpft sind bei omikron sieht
es so aus dass dann auch ältere und
mittelalte personen bei omikron kein
höheres risiko mehr haben als bei einer
influenza aber geimpfte sie müssen
geimpft sein und dann ist das das ende
der pandemie das heißt impfen der
hochaltrigen und der vor erkrankten zu
möglichst 100 prozent heißt dass wir die
pandemie bekämpfungsmaßnahmen
beenden könnten und dass wir ein
versprechen finde ich was aller mühen
wert werden ich versuche sie zu
verstehen dass sie sagen es gibt ein
allgemeines lebensrisiko dazu gehören
auch krankheiten und wenn jetzt das
risiko an koronaren im prinzip so hoch
oder niedrig ist wie bei einer starken
grippe dann gibt es keine rechtfertigung
mehr für corona weil wir sonst auch bei
einer grippe maßnahmen ergreifen müssten
wir müssen ja halbwegs kohärent sein wir
können zum beispiel sage ich mal als
münchner die wiesen nicht mehr
veranstalten weil die meistens zusammen
fällt mit der ausbreitung von influenza
und anderen die vier coronaviren die
traditionellen spiele auch eine rolle
bei diesen typischen auftreten
erkrankungen und niemand soll das
verharmlosen wir hatten 1917 18 nach
angaben des lka
25.100 todesfälle in der influenza welle
20 17h
25.100 als exzess mortalität errechnet
nicht aufgrund der daten der mediziner
die waren nämlich ein paar tausend das
heißt dass es ernst und in italien ist
das teilweise noch viel höher gegangen
das heißt wir haben durch in florenz
eine massive belastung und trotzdem
haben wir da bislang jedenfalls auf
maßnahmen verpflichten verzichtet und
ich würde dringend dazu raten diese
debatte nicht zu beginnen jetzt bei
influenza in zukunft shutter und block
down masken tragen wiesen absagen das zu
beginnen wir müssen wieder zur
normalität zurück
das war corinna nachgehakt diesmal mit
professor julian nida-rümelin herzlichen
dank und herzlichen dank an sie zu hause
viel interesse bleiben sie sind
[Musik]